[Music]
salty sweet chewy crunchy it's a
delicious combination born from one of
black America's most consequential
cultural movements it was the 1930s the
place was New York City
it was the epicenter of black Americans
movement into mainstream culture the
Harlem Renaissance artists writers and
thinkers would gather at venues and
Harlem into the wee hours of the morning
listening to touring big bands and jazz
artists as the club stayed open later
and later
so did local restaurants too taking the
hungry concert goers in one such
restaurant owner was Josie T Wells
founder of Wells supper club Wells
became known for its southern inspired
menu but Wells needed a hit to stay on
top of the 2 a.m. restaurant business
what could he do
seeing an opportunity Wells realized
that the fried chicken leftovers from
dinner could be served with the freshly
prepared waffles for breakfast creating
a sweet and savory concoction unlike
anything else the dish was a hit
eventually word got out and chicken and
waffles became a soul food staple from
Atlanta to Los Angeles and though Wells
closed in 1982 the dish lives on so when
you think of the Harlem Renaissance take
Duke Ellington jazz planks and Hughes
poetry and Joseph T Wells chicken and
waffles
[Music]
[Music]
if you want a pastrami sandwich go to
Casa de me if you want to chat please
come to Heidi thing this my friends is
the story of the real New Yorker
sandwich and the people who keep the
legacy alive I've been teaching here for
20 years any tourists in the world enjoy
the hot doggies but all you New Yorkers
know in the chat pieces on 110th and 1st
Avenue
inside the bodega best known as Hajis we
meet Salah my name is Salah Parvati and
I'm the manager of Hajis Dillon grocery
for 50 meters we actually invent the
chap cheese your boss so they get to
chotchkie's we're eating on it
[Music]
the ingredients is one burger for
example or two burgers you chop it up
good and you put it with some system
that's the secret decision and whatever
you like like lettuce tomatoes onion
that's Sanders is an Arabic food but we
don't add cheese over there but when we
come here we do cheese only on a roll is
375 on a hero that's cost like five
dollars
Hajis is located in a part of New York
that's made up of various kinds of
people with a variety of incomes so
keeping chopped cheese at a price point
everyone can afford has been a top
priority in fact the chopped cheese has
only gone up a dollar in the last decade
we are here for all time helping the
community and serving the community
chef cheese is like everything to the
community because it's affordable and
delicious so everybody liked it we sell
about 200 is Jeff kisses and a cosplay
of the chopped cheese has spread beyond
Harlem and into bodegas far and wide
attracting loyal New Yorkers everywhere
it appears but in the end it all comes
back to Hajis and Salah the chef cheese
every day but for me sometimes I don't
need to choose
I make it like a chap hamburger it's the
same thing but no cheese I'm trying to
lose weight that's all
[Music]
I've been kicking people off the Apollo
stage for what 31 years if you're not
good enough you get booed off the stage
the audience loved it
I'm CP lacy the executioner at the world
famous Apollo Theater all together now
[Music]
welcome to the Apollo ever tonight are
you ready Amateur Night at the Apollo is
the granddaddy to all of these shows
that you look at today x-factor
America's Got Talent American Idol you
come and you sing or you dance or you do
your magic or tell a joke a poem and the
audience will decide whether you go on
to the next level or whether you get
booed off of the stage that's where I
come in my role is to educate you about
your own Talent
or lack thereof our booing policy is
this there's a blue here Abu there abou
here then the booths just get paramount
we have a noise leader backstage and
when it reached a certain boo level the
next thing you know there's a siren
enter the executioner to kick you off of
my stage the executioner character
changes after every execution at the top
of the show I'll Gong someone off it's
Michael Jackson you've been hit by
you've been struck by a boom criminal
The Godfather of Soul James Brown so
true so true you just got a boot dance
that's that hit man Prince Lilly Lilly
[Music]
the Apollo Theater is a place where we
as African Americans could go and
perform folks like Ella Fitzgerald Sammy
Davis jr. James Brown and Lauryn Hill
have graced the Apollo stage I don't
enjoy kicking people off the stage per
se if time allows I try to get to the
person who got booed off the stage and
just encourage them and console them go
back to the woodshed learn your craft
and come back and when you're very very
good we'll give you the claps the Apollo
always invite you to come back and try
again every week without fail when they
say here's the execution they're saying
good night to you folks thanks for
coming in there's always someone that
goes boo I hate you they just love being
a part of the Apollo audience
[Music]
when you put on a hat it gives you
height and it gives you power for us
church hats are not just passed they are
crowns and when a woman puts one on she
becomes a queen my name is Iveta petty
I'm Kathy Anderson and I am one chambers
we've been making hats for more than 20
years a church hat is a very special hat
especially in the african-american
community as a child growing up in the
South in the 60s we always wore hats
sunday is the one day historically that
we had a chance and we step out in our
Sunday best I don't believe that church
hats are a thing of the past
[Music]
I have noticed that the younger
generation is taking on the tradition of
wearing hats it makes me happy to see a
younger woman with the Hat on her head
because I know that she's still carrying
on the tradition
I come from a long line of church
hat-wearing women everyone war had it
was a parade
it was colors it was magic
when you go to churching and you step in
and you see all of your sisters wear
hats on we all be eyeing each other and
under our brushing or that's a really
gorgeous hat so it's wonderful to be in
a room filled with women with hats on
and each one of us look absolutely
amazing in our alright pop quiz hotshot
you're in Harlem and you're at this
building you go through the door enter
the security code take the elevator to
the third floor knock on this door where
Rudy greets you hi and welcome make your
way into a packed apartment and try to
find a seat what do you get you get a
live jazz performance like no other
[Music]
every Sunday Marjorie Elliot and her son
Rudel drear's
open the doors to their apartment for
people to come and listen to jazz music
we decided to use our apartment because
we can do what we want here it's just a
matter of this is home
so everybody walk through that door we
treat his family and it's a pretty big
family the concerts are so popular that
if you're not on time finding a seat can
be a little tricky we fill up the living
room the kitchen hallway people will
stand out taking videos it's pretty much
like that every Sunday now you know it's
like it's jam-packed
the jazz concerts began in 1993 after
rudel's brother Phil passed away well my
brother passed away on the Sunday and
mommy has a great idea to honor him with
concerts on Sundays
you know when you play music you just
get all your angst out and then it's
just a healing feeling so I think our
thing was you know what better way to
honor him and with the concert and we've
been blessed to never Evans to Sunday
[Applause]
with their commitment and consistency to
play every Sunday the concerts are now
considered legendary in Harlem
attracting audiences from all over the
world
hey Rudel do you mind if we ask some of
the audience members where they came
from
of course I'm from Germany France
Australia yeah that's pretty cool I
[Music]
think once we started it just took on a
life force of its own sometimes people
come and they just they don't know what
they're gonna expect you know it's like
rang a bell and get free jazz and then
once they get here and they have that
experience it's kind of something they
won't forget
[Music]
[Applause]
for some people this is their church you
become here and I feel renewed and we
feel renewed and you never know when
you're gonna touch out there so you're
putting out good energy it's gonna work